madame monsieur bonjour la princesse de
galles lady di est morte cette nuit à
paris dans un accident de voiture elle
se trouvait avec son ami le milliardaire
saoudien dodi al fayed mort lui aussi
ainsi que le chauffeur de la voiture un
employé de l'hôtel ritz le garde du
corps de lady di lui est grièvement
blessé lady di et dodi al-fayed était
arrivé hier à paris au sortir du ritz un
hôtel qui appartient au père de dodi al
fayed
leur voiture une mercedes noire a été
prise en chasse par des paparazzi
l'accident a eu lieu dans le tunnel du
pont de l'alma vers minuit le chauffeur
a perdu le contrôle de la mercedes qui
roulait semble-t-il à très très vive
allure
dodi al fayed et le chauffeur sont
semble-t-il mort sur le coup la
princesse elle est décédée quatre heures
plus tard à l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière sur ces événements de la
nuit
le récit de pascal golomer des tôles
déchiqueté le moteur droit et l'état de
la voiture témoigne de la violence
extrême du sud il est 0 en france
lorsque lady diana xi au restaurant de
l'hôtel ritz en compagnie de simon no
body al fayed
un chauffeur de l'hôtel est au volant un
agent de sécurité de la princesse à ses
côtés mais la voiture est poursuivi par
plusieurs photographes à moto
elle pénètre dans le tunnel de l'alma en
plein paris à 100 150 km/heure peut-être
plus le chauffeur perd le contrôle et la
voiture percute très violemment les
parois du tunnel lorsque la police et
les secours arrivent sur les lieux de
dial fayed est déjà décédé tout comme le
chauffeur
la princesse de galles elle doit être
désincarcéré l'opération prend plus
d'une heure avant le transfert à
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière
l'enquète débute tout juste les
photographes sont interrogés les motos
saisies comme pièces à conviction
mais la fin car 50 à l'hôpital
le professeur riou patron de l'équipe de
réanimation au voc la presse
dans la côte ont mis d'urgence a mis en
évidence une plaie importante de la
veine pulmonaire gauche malgré la
fermeture de cette plaie et un massage
cardiaque externe et interne de djoser
aucune efficacité circulatoire n'a pu
être rétablie et le décès défense l'a t
à 4 heures du matin quant aux
journalistes photographes ils sont
toujours entendus quai des orfèvres par
les enquêteurs de la brigade criminelle
voilà monsieur rebonjour pour cette
édition spéciale après la disparition
tragique de l'année dernière
disparition accidentelle de la princesse
lady diana 36 ans donc qui est morte à
paris dans un accident de voiture qui a
également tué son compagnon dodi al
fayed le fils d'un milliardaire égyptien
avec lequel elle vivait depuis quelques
semaines quelques mois voire maintenant
disparition également du chauffeur de la
voiture et le garde du corps a été très
grièvement blessé visiblement cet
accident a eu lieu alors que la voiture
était poursuivi par un certain nombre de
photographes de la presse à scandale les
paparazzi comme on dit en italien
l'accident a eu lieu je vous le rappelle
au beau milieu de la nuit sous le tunnel
du pont de l'alma à paris je vous
propose avant d'aller plus loin
d'entendre des témoignages de voir
comment maintenant les choses vont se
dérouler la suite des événements donc et
les conséquences sur la monarchie
britannique de nous rappeler simplement
en quelques minutes les circonstances de
l'accident pascal golomer une carcasse
littéralement broyé l'état de la voiture
témoigne de la violence extrême du
cirque
la puissante mercedes était lancé à
pleine vitesse dans le tunnel de l'alma
en plein paris vers 0 h 30 sans doute
plus de 150 km pour une raison encore
inconnue
elle est venue refait le mur puis l'un
des piliers du tunnel à son bord quatre
personnes
lady diana son ami dodi al fayed un
garde du corps et le chauffeur il venait
de quitter l'hôtel ritz place vendôme
pour fausser compagnie aux paparazzi qui
les suivaient à moto le chauffeur aurait
alors décidé de rouler très vite trop
vite
lorsque la police et les secours
arrivent sur place dodi al fayed et le
chauffeur sont déjà décédés la princesse
de galles
elle peut être désincarcéré l'opération
prend plus d'une heure avant le
transfert vers l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière
pendant ce temps l'enquète débute cette
photographe sont rapidement emmené par
les locaux de la brigade criminelle
les motos sont saisis comme pièces à
conviction peu avant 6 heures à
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière
les journalistes sont conviés à une
conférence de presse improvisée
thoracotomie d'urgence a mis en évidence
qui ne plaît important de la veine
pulmonaire gauche malgré la fermeture de
cette plaie et un massage cardiaque
externe et interne djoser aucune
efficacité circulatoire n'a pu être
rétablie il décède et frappé à quatre
heures du matin que dressent les
condoléances de la france à la famille
royale aux familles des victimes et au
peuple britannique tout entier lady
diana
mais c'est une personne très aimé en
france une femme moderne courageuse
sensible à la détresse humaine sa
disparition sera ressentie
douloureusement dans notre pays
quai des orfèvres les sept photographes
sont alors toujours interrogé par les
enquêteurs de la brigade criminelle
le jour se lève les premiers parisien se
présente sous le tunnel de l'alma ou
rendre un dernier hommage à lady diana
princesse de galles
la mercedes 280 rouler très vite trouve
plus de 150 kilomètres heures selon gère
sans témoin le compteur lui se serait
bloqué aux alentours des 200 sites en
france oui les spécialistes n'en firent
est pour l'instant une solution
définitive il faudra attendre la fin des
exercices
l'élément nouveau lui est parvenue du
parquet de paris cet après midi
henri-paul le sauveur qui travaillait au
ritz conduisait en état d'ébriété un
gramme 75 d'alcool dans le sang
au lieu des 0,5 toléré par la
législation française
le chauffeur aurait-il alors perdu tout
seul le contrôle de sa voiture
ou encore comme l'expliquent un témoin
l'avocat de la famille al-fayed
aurait-il été gêné par un motard qui
zigzaguait devant lui il a pensé qu'il
s'agissait d'un cortège officiel
et puis à une étrange dans le tunnel de
l'alma
il a ensuite vu une moto qui se trouvait
devant le véhicule mercedes city
semblait et c'est tenter d'empêcher sa
progression seule la trésorerie jones
garde du corps de lady diana unique
survivant de l'accident pourrait
confirmer ou non cette hypothèse
une hypothèse que les enquêteurs
jugerait cependant peu probable
l'implication directe dans l'accident
des paparazzi pourrait même être écarté
leurs motos se serait trouvé au moins à
100 m derrière la voiture
reste alors la polémique sur l'attitude
des photographes
après l'accident des photographes une
main anonyme a déjà désigné comme
coupable
c'était moins américains arrivés avant
les secours ont effectivement eu des
photographes autour de la voiture mais
il ne parle pas de gêne particulière
oui on a vu des photographes et qu'est
ce qu'il faisait mais autour de la
voiture prendre des photos mais il
le courrier d'autres en revanche affirmé
avoir vu mitraillé la voiture les
paparazzi aurait-il continuer à prendre
des photos sans avoir essayé de porter
secours
c'est sur cette notion de non assistance
à personne en danger
il faudrait être poursuivi
le parcours entre kensington et l'abbaye
de westminster les sentes associations
caritatives auxquelles diana participé
d'une façon ou d'une autre
seront représentés dans le cortège ces
derniers temps diana s'étaient beaucoup
investis dans la lutte contre
l'exclusion et le sida et puis ensuite
pour la suppression des mines
antipersonnel le destin a voulu que mère
teresa disparaissent également hier
celle qui avait choisi de consacrer sa
vie aux plus pauvres d'entre les plus
pauvres s'est éteinte à quelques temps
il avait 87 ans les deux femmes se
connaissaient s'apprécier et mère teresa
avait justement fait savoir qu'elles ne
pourraient pas assister aux obsèques de
lady diana
geneviève moll et didier jan admirait
profondément mère teresa qu'elle
considérait comme un exemple vivant de
charité quelque part son action la
guider la princesse de galles comme
chaque princesse de la famille royale
visitez les jeunes accouchées bien sûr
mais diana ne se déplaçait jamais sans
demander à rencontrer des enfants
souffrant de nice y at-il dans un
service de maladies génétiques notamment
eric de l'enfant en visite à paris pour
une soirée de charité de la fondation
pour l'enfance anne aymone giscard
d'estaing elle se rend dans une classe
d'un quartier défavorisé de la capitale
cette compassion elle va la mettre en
oeuvre pour lutter contre le cancer et
plus fortement encore contre le sida
là elle prendra même des positions très
appuyé quelqu'un sida me rends pas ceux
qui en sont intenables dans la colonne
pour aider les plus démunis pour venir
au secours de ceux qui n'ont rien elle
vend même une pincée de sa garde-robe
chez christie's à new york
les produits de la vente vont à des
oeuvres caritatives
au début de cette année elle découvre
les ravages causés sur les civils par
les mines antipersonnel au cambodge en
particulier et la lutte contre ces
engins de mort qui mutile 2000 personnes
par an devient son principal combat
début juillet elle se rend en bosnie où
chaque jour senin font toujours des
victimes
elle écoute à sarajevo le récit de deux
jeunes garçons l'un sert l'autre
musulman qui ont perdu une jambe à cause
de ces mines sont combats acharnés
avaient immédiatement rallier l'adhésion
du premier ministre tony blair à l'idée
d'une interdiction totale de ces engins
à oslo les participants à la conférence
contre les mines antipersonnel ont
observé lundi une minute de silence en
hommage à la princesse de galles le
monde entier représentés dans cette
salle rendait hommage à celle qui avait
choisi d'utiliser son image et sa voix
revient le malheur des autres
dix mois après l'effroyable accident qui
a coûté la vie à la princesse de galles
sous le tunnel du pont de l'alma à paris
tous les protagonistes et témoin du
drame on se retrouvait de mât à
l'occasion d'une confrontation générale
au palais de justice de paris
cette enquête n'est pas encore terminé
mais on peut déjà dire qu'elle restera
sans doute dans l'histoire comme celle
qui aura mobilisé le plus grand nombre
d'enquêteurs en france et dans le monde
valérie ermite emmanuel bec juste au
dessus du tunnel de l'alma la flamme de
la liberté a toujours autant de succès
ce n'était pas sa vocation première
mais la sculpture est subitement devenu
un mémorial dédié à la princesse diana
le temps du souvenir du recueillement et
celui de l' enquête
demain les deux juges d'instruction
convoquerons tous les photographes et
une quinzaine de témoins tous présents
au moment de l'accident
ou juste après peut-être l'un des
derniers actes d'instruction d'une
enquête exceptionnelle
au lendemain de l'accident mortel la
presse du monde entier attend pour
filmer les paparazzi arrêtés la nuit
même est mise en examen pour homicide
involontaire et non assistance à
personne en danger
sur le pont de l'alma une main anonyme a
déjà désigné les coupables les rangs
grand 75 d'alcool retrouvé dans le sang
dans ripol le chauffeur de la mercedes
suggère une autre lecture du dossier
mais une partie de l'opinion publique et
des médias anglais ont du mal à s'y
résigner des médias britanniques qui
hier encore se demander si l'on ne
s'était pas trompé dans les analyses
voir si henri paul n'avait pas été
empoisonné aujourd'hui l'on sait
pourtant que ces dos dit lui-même qui a
décidé qu henri paul conduirait ce soir
là ce qui n'empêche pas son père mohamed
al fayed d'évoquer régulièrement
l'hypothèse d'un complot
le milliardaire égyptien s'est même payé
les services d'un détective privé pierre
ottavioli ancien chef de la brigade
criminelle parce que vous partez soins
thèse de l'accident est ce que tout est
possible et ce qu'elle attend pas que tu
aimes chose qui peut tenir encore pour
vous pour vous avez raison pour laquelle
a vu naître prématurés parce que pour
répondre aux questions il faut pas trop
sur accident ce qu'elle semble mais il
faut aussi éviter aussi lui n'était
qu'une pure vente a pas encore de mot
les tabloïds anglais mais aussi leur
enquête
le mirror penser par exemple avoir
retrouvé la voiture qui a été percutée
par la mercedes scouts
ce ne serait pas une fiat uno mais une
ax bien sûr l'information était fausse
car c'est l'une des certitudes de ce
dossier sorti des laboratoires de la
gendarmerie
les débris de phares et les traces de
peinture retrouvée sur la mercedes
proviennent bien d'une fiat uno blanche
la chasse à la petite voiture fut donc
ouverte en région parisienne plus de
2006 à tous nous ont été contrôlés sans
succès jugo juice
un certain nombre ses statuts la victime
city seul le caractère exceptionnel de
la situation et demain les neuf
photographes et le motard de presse
seront confrontés aux témoins
photographiée ici par des touristes le
31 août dernier
leur attitude après l'accident sera une
dernière fois examinés il me manquera
alors plus que l'analyse des composants
électroniques du véhicule et sa vitesse
exacte pour que le dossier soit bouclé
et à moins d'un rebondissement
l'anc est pour l'instant ne parle que
d'un accident de voiture
certains se sont installés depuis hier
soir aux abords du palais de justice de
paris
la place est chère pour les équipes de
télévision françaises mais surtout
étrangère c'est que le moment est
supposé être d'importance
mohamed al fayed en personne est à paris
pour assister lui aussi à la
confrontation générale il ya tellement
de preuves d'éléments différents que
j'espère que le juge parviendra à dire
lesquels sont justes pour reconstituer
ce qui s'est passé confiant par rapport
à cette confrontation
oui il ya toujours de l'espoir quand on
croit en dieu
l'espoir que dieu trouvera la vérité
pour nous depuis peu mohammad al fayed a
décidé de parler aux caméras
c'est lui qui aurait souhaité venir à la
confrontation à ses côtés d'autres
parties civiles sont là la mère de la
princesse diana et les parents du
chauffeur de la mercedes henri-paul seul
trait vers lee jones unique rescapé
toujours amnésique est absent un à un
les photographes sont convoqués à la
barre à chaque fois ils sont confrontés
avec les témoins présents sur les lieux
de l'accident comme le docteur mayev le
premier à avoir soigné diana lui a
toujours dit que les photographes ne
l'avait pas gêné dans son travail
d'autres témoins parlent en revanche
d'une attitude agressive de la part des
photographes
c'est pour y voir définitivement plus
clair que la confrontation qui durera
toute la journée a été organisée
je vous le disais en titre depuis ce
matin au palais de justice de paris la
confrontation des témoins du drame neuf
mois après la mort de la princesse diana
le juge devrait déterminer quelle fut
notamment l'attitude après l'accident
est la part de responsabilité des
photographes présents sur les lieux
une journée marquée par la présence de
la mère diana et de mohamed al-fayed
valérie enit pascal caron difficile de
rater mohamed al fayed a lorsqu'il est à
paris une horde de gardes du corps trois
voitures luxueuses et des membres de sa
sécurité qui filme les journalistes plus
que d'habitude encore le milliardaire
égyptien avait décidé de ne pas passer
inaperçu allant même jusqu'à parler
devant les caméras il ya tellement de
preuves d'éléments différents
j'espère que le juge parviendra à dire
lesquels sont justes afin de
reconstituer ce qui s'est passé mais
c'est à l'intérieur du palais qui s'est
le plus exprimé les photographes
si je n'étais pas devant un tribunal je
les prendrais dit-il tout en souriant
plus incisif encore il parle de la mer
de diana ordinaire vous comprenez de la
classe des travailleurs
ll se prend pour la reine de saba alors
ils ne parlent pas la mère de diana mais
pas entendu ces propos
c'est la première fois qu'elle venait à
paris dans le cadre de cette instruction
tout comme les parents d'henri paul le
chauffeur de la mercedes
tous sont venus pour écouter les
photographes confrontés aux témoins de
l'accident
comme ce médecin par exemple qui a
prodigué les premiers soins à diana
tenté - 10 heures leur a dit à prendre
de photos encore une fois c'est une
appréciation moral sera le comportement
des photographes est actuellement pas
une incrimination pénale au profit des
gens
une non-assistance à personne à danger
et à la limite un homicide involontaire
alors que on sait parfaitement et on le
sait depuis le surlendemain de
l'accident que l'école c'est un accident
ne sont rien d'autre que l'état
d'ivresse dû chauffeur et la conduite
excessive du véhicule alors on s'est mis
en route
10 - parties civiles ou photographes
chacun a campé sur ses positions la
confrontation s'est terminée sans
apporter d'éléments mouvants peut-être
la fin du feuilleton judiciaire dans la
sphère lady di deux ans après la mort de
la princesse diana de son ami dodi al
fayed et de leur chauffeur
le parquet de paris a requis un non lieu
général pour les photographes mise en
examen le ministère public estime donc
qu'il n'existe pas de charges
suffisantes contre les paparazzi
grand-portage emmanuel gagné dorothée
cochard et loïc moines y deux ans
d'investigations d' expertise d'audition
rarement un accident aura donné lieu à
un tel déploiement de moyens
six enquêteurs de la brigade criminelle
ont travaillé à plein temps sur ce
dossier
celui d'une course poursuite entre une
princesse et des paparazzi qui a tourné
au drame
après l'accident mortel neuf
photographes et un motard de presse ont
été mises en examen pour homicide
involontaire et non-assistance à
personne en danger
aujourd'hui le parquet de paris demandé
un non lieu général pour les avocats des
photographes
c'est l'aboutissement logique de
l'enquète le chauffeur n'est sûr mais
paul était sous l'emprise financière
d'un état alcoolique était n'était pas
titulaire de la licence pouvoir conduire
le véhicule qu'il conduisait et pire
encore qu on disait beaucoup trop vite
et a priori effectivement l'instruction
a démontré que ce sont les causes
directes de l'accident qui a causé la
mort de lady diana et 2
de dodi al fayed et on ne peut pas
imputer la responsabilité de cet
accident photographe aujourd'hui le
parquet n'émet qu'un avis et aux juges
chargés de l'enquêté qu'appartient la
décision de prononcer un non lieu ou de
renvoyer les photographes en
correctionnelle sa décision devrait être
connue avant la fin du mois en attendant
la recommandation du parquet réjoui
l'avocat du garde du corps de lady di
seul rescapé de l'accident pour celui
qui les fait entrer vos rides jaune
les enquêteurs se sont trompés de cible
les responsables sont pour moi ceux qui
ont obligé le conducteur à prendre cette
voiture alors même qu'il n'avait pas la
licence appropriée et pas l'habitude de
conduire cette voiture et qu'il était
ivre et sous l'emprise et médicaments et
ceux là sont comme ces derniers par les
dirigeants du [ __ ] et en limousine
c'est à dire la société qui a loué la
mer c'est d'être
quant à mohamed al fayed le père de dodi
et propriétaire du ritz
il se refuse pour l'instant à tout
commentaire partie civile dans le
dossier
il reste persuadé que les didier et son
fils ont été les victimes d'un complot
deux ans presque jour pour jour après
l'accident mortel de la princesse diana
le parquet de paris vient de requérir un
non-lieu général et le ministère public
demande donc l'abandon des poursuites à
l'encontre des neuf photographes et du
motard de presse mise en examen n'est
c'est au juge d'instruction maintenant
que revient la décision de poursuivre ou
non
valérie ermite fagnot verdict deux ans
d'une sine nomine l enquête sur un
tragique et médiatique accident peu
après mini ce 31 août 97 diana dodi al
fayed et leur chauffeur henri paul
trouvent la mort dans le tunnel de
l'alma premiers coupables désignés les
photographes ils suivent le couple
depuis la matinée et ce serait pour
l'heure échapper que la princesse serait
mort
ce n'est que plus tard que le taux
d'alcoolémie du chauffeur de la mercedes
sera connu henri paul avait bu et pris
des médicaments
de plus henri paul roulait beaucoup trop
vite et sa mercedes a versé une fiat uno
encore introuvable à ce jour pour le
parquet de paris weil amas de dial fayed
et henri-paul sont donc mort d'un
accident de la circulation et les
photographes n'ont pas à être poursuivi
le parquet s'est rendu compte qu'il n'y
avait aucun élément juridique qui
permettait de poursuivre les
photographes
encore une fois on ne peut porter le
jugement moral que l'on veut sur le
comportement qu'ils ont pu avoir mais
sur un faux lent que sur un plan
juridique il n'y a aucun comportement
pénalement répréhensible seul survivant
de l'accident
13h08 jones le garde du corps tenez plus
tôt pour responsable la direction de
l'hôtellerie tu pourras voir confier la
voiture à un non professionnel et non
voulait en aucun cas aux photographes
personnellement elle s'est aussi à vis
de mon client est toujours le sentiment
que les photographes je n'étais pas
responsable de cet accident qui est dû à
un chauffard ivre qui n'est pas la
licence appropriée et à l'hôtel ritz qui
a exigé que ces chauffeurs conduisent
par conséquent je ne peux me réjouis
pour les photographes
même si je ne les défends pas qu' il ne
soit plus poursuivis par le parquet
injoignable pour l'instant le père de
dodi mohamed al fayed sera
vraisemblablement l'un des seuls à
contester ces réquisitions
un non lieu qui n'est cependant pas
définitif les juges d'instruction de
vidal et stefan vont maintenant décider
seul si les photographes doivent être
poursuivis ou non
[Musique]